my world are you doing thanks for coming
to the set of our new video when I was a
day you say a baby thanks sake steaks
ligo na only et was invited behind the
scenes of todrick hall's latest creation
steak and eggs first of all I'm not
bright enough well baby should we fix
ain't nothing but a thing how do I look
a moment of silence dang the world whoo
della fresh you look fresh I so clean
clean I'm just trying to be in the video
shake shake shake and a parody music
video for his new YouTube red series
sing it my character is kind of like a
has-been artist who had a hit single
that was you know like back I feel like
it was back in the 90s this is like the
thong song of saying it the 10-episode
series centers around a singing
competition show and experience todrick
knows all too well somebody
and a lot of people don't know the the
politics and the crazy shenanigans that
happened behind the scenes of these
really successful hit shows until I
think this is really cool because it
gives the audience a peek behind the
curtain of what actually happens to make
these people win or lose these shows so
what does actually happen todrick well
baby I can't tell you all that because
miss Simon Cowell will come for me and I
gotta ask does it feel like a full
circle moment cuz you know obviously you
audition for American Idol this show is
on YouTube red and you've obviously
created a huge space for yourself on
that platform so yeah it's like my two
worlds combine did you see when girls
too I love me and with this music video
you rotate your directing it you're
starring in it I costume are you cut you
owe you dress them too of course you did
you put that Taj of flair on anything
alright think you should make a cameo
I'm trying let's get the crew in with
your reading dancer guys come on
everybody hello Eddie holy oh oh oh yeah
boss Oh